[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm just
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
up
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Music]
and then four
wow
yes
oh my gosh this dress is fabulous
[Music]
this is prime real estate baby
[Music]
hi mickey
[Music]
wow
all right
foreign
[Music]
bye
what's going on
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
know
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
just
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
eh
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
huh
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Applause]
oh my gosh
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon yale college class of
2021
welcome to the graduates of berkeley
davenport benjamin franklin
and pauly murray colleges
and welcome to family friends and
members of the class
who are joining us virtually via live
stream
we are so excited to have arrived at
this special day
in a few moments we will begin
announcing the graduates as they process
across the commencement stage here in
front of me
but before we start our program a few
words about the land
on which today's ceremony is taking
place
yale acknowledges that indigenous
peoples and nations
including mohegan mashintaka pequot
eastern pequot scattercock
golden hill pogosit niantic
and the quinnipiac and other algonquin
speaking peoples
have stewarded through generations the
lands and waterways
of what is now the state of connecticut
we honor
and respect the enduring relationship
that exists between these peoples and
nations and this land thank you and
please enjoy the program
mr president i have the honor to present
candidates from berkeley college for the
bachelor's degrees
in yale college when they have been
recommended by the faculty
of yale college and approved by the
corporation
dean chun will ask you by your official
act
to confer upon them these degrees
by the authority vested in me i shall
confer upon you
the bachelor's degrees in yale college
when designated by the dean
and shall then admit you to all their
rights
and responsibilities
ellen margaret andrews the banner bearer
of berkeley college
rachel coyle and amy zang the procession
marshals of berkeley college
pradi vanayak aggarwal
[Music]
colin bachioco
jennifer leticia benuelas
oshani basu chaudhry
[Music]
nehabat
madeleine blaney
kelvin brobee
grace chiang hui chen
allison yon-chan
eduardo custodio leal
[Applause]
james foster dunn
[Music]
michelle erdensana
danielle esposito
kelsey olya evans
abigail virginia fortier congratulations
tomiko michelle freisen
[Music]
william j gallagher
[Music]
oshu shane katanaga
juwan gomez aguilar
danielle harris
lydia ross hill
julian johnson
[Applause]
charlotte cavalier
caleb john kim
ananya kumar banerjee
[Applause]
young
claire elizabeth laffin
olivia levine
alice lee
brian lynn
[Applause]
[Music]
henry c liu
david lund
[Applause]
timothy larson lose
caroline lewis mcgavern
zev a mayor
tanvi mihir
helena maria maleo
william thayer mitchell
[Applause]
brianna arielle moore
brian oliveira
[Music]
qse omran
daniel o'reilly
anthony m orr
brian lou owens
allegra oh pancreats
amir patel
[Applause]
catherine aura peyton
aladia khalifakir patterson
pommier
victoria isabel quintanilla
brian reyes
[Applause]
andrews saint claire richards
marissa rivera
doud chad
veronica sosa
william arthur sussman
mary tate
washiki tibbetts
[Applause]
vasquez
candace wong
[Music]
[Applause]
michael whalen
andesia
annie yang
mary jacqueline yap
joanna zukin
[Applause]
and the graduates participating remotely
tillman frederick
bartles-meyer jenna marie
kaufman irene kim
joanna masihiwa chas
niway trevor kyle passmore
shawn michael pigeon isabella tang
elise vanderwood and hannah wood
congratulations berkeley class of 2021
[Applause]
mr president i have the honor to present
candidates from paulie murray college
for the bachelor's degrees in yale
college
when they have been recommended by the
faculty of yale college
and approved by the corporation dean
chung will ask you by your official act
to confer upon them these degrees
[Applause]
by the authority vested in me i shall
confer upon you
the bachelor's degrees in yale college
when designated by the dean
and shall then admit you to all their
rights and responsibilities
banner bearer for paulie murray college
lincoln thatcher berkeley and ileana
sophia valdez
procession marshals of poly murray
college
moro aceves acosta
[Music]
akshi agarwal
aliya halil ahmad
[Applause]
naomi ariano
[Applause]
[Applause]
jackson robert bando
[Applause]
michael philip bleacher
sam isaac kame brakash
[Applause]
brandon ronald chambers
felicia chang
michael youngjun chang
james joseph check
hey chen
esther yuna choi
riley drew constable
ryan cantos
[Applause]
lukash robert corey
christian ryan crop
[Music]
[Applause]
daniel joseph deprimio
[Applause]
emilia lynn drake
yara noor al-khatib
[Applause]
matthew john erickson
lucas curry ferrer
heather jane foster
chris eugene fowler jr
mila freeman
kevin paul gallagher jr
yashin gao
griffin douglas garrity
patricia annetta gorska
jordan adam grody
[Applause]
ann jordan
alexander juliker
nase kanko arthur
[Music]
nash doris bunfield kais
[Applause]
jacqueline elizabeth noblesdorf
kate hypatia kushner
julia morgan latham
[Applause]
kyung ah viola lee
justin weaver lilly
claudia
tessa violet malone
danielle martin
richard molu
[Music]
katherine milwaukee
anahid lal mobaraki
sarah michelle monahan
hannah ray moreno
emma joan miller
claire margaret o'mara
jude anthony salada um
[Music]
mitchell benjamin ostrow
joshua glenn palmer
rowan mckenzie palmer
johann john park
ryan patrick parkey
amanda lloyd patterson
[Applause]
shannon caitlin taylor panetta
jordan howell
anne chanwang
keshev adithya ragavan
andrew paul reardon
stephen michael riley
[Music]
emily margaret richards
cesar rodriguez
[Music]
kevin omar san isella
anthony enrique danny sarkis
lydia bennett shaw
renee anna sue
when she son
benjamin kyle tillinger
[Music]
michelle christina tong
[Applause]
gabriel vasquez
nicholas landon wade
[Applause]
daniel junghan wong
skye alexandra de la veron ward
laura lee weyland
[Music]
amira kaylee williams
tiffany wong
reese maxwell nguyen
jonathan alex shu
hugh lam vanessa yan
[Music]
angela zhao
sophia zhao
and the graduates participating remotely
patrick brown
matan cutler marley claire
finley philip carney kent
xiaoyu ma ciara ostrander
jay zhang from prof t and me much lemur
love congratulations to the inaugural
class of pawley murray college
[Music]
[Applause]
mr president i have the honor to present
candidates
from davenport college for the
bachelor's degrees
in yale college when they have been
recommended by the faculty of yale
college
and approved by the corporation dean
chun will ask you
by your official act to confer upon them
these degrees
by the authority vested in me i shall
confer upon you the bachelor's degrees
in yale college
when designated by the dean and shall
then admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities
jason bradley camp and aydah nas dench
the banner bearers of davenport college
chelsea nicole ilarde and alissa
chisu yoon the procession marshals of
davenport college
ayo dimiji
[Applause]
cameron james fisher allen
[Applause]
jessica yoonju bay
clay andrew bailey ii
steven dennis barbie
[Applause]
alexandra a bauman
amira elizabeth billings
victoria bonanno
robert anthony brinkman
joshua collier brooks
[Applause]
nicole aaron press gravey brussel faria
maxwell g boo
[Applause]
natalia castellanos gonzalez
[Applause]
[Applause]
ray chickering
[Applause]
[Music]
ariel elena claxton
danielle alexis collins
lee khande
[Music]
patrick lawrence kante
nicholas ryan dahl
[Music]
corset elizabeth davis
[Music]
[Applause]
amy c de la brier
lauren nicole dreissich
genesis victoria duran
[Applause]
natalie anne marie e
a ponge waiter kaki
[Applause]
[Music]
noah david gershenson
chloe alexandra heller
henderson edward heiser
caleb t hillridge
[Applause]
[Music]
christopher james hudludzig
alexander west heiser hoban
[Applause]
lucas joachim holter
emily rose howell
amanda ibanez
[Music]
[Applause]
abdullah ibrahim mohammed ahmed
jaina jaina hey
connor w k johnson
[Applause]
nikita joshi
[Applause]
[Applause]
jonathan george kraft
morgan ellie lawson
alexis k lizor
[Music]
[Applause]
boo liu
[Applause]
nicholas morin mcnabb
[Applause]
canning olivia malkin
[Music]
daniel james marsh
[Applause]
martinez castillo
ethan david mcbride
william francis mcgint the second
brian mendoza
christian a million santiago
mohammed iran munchie
[Music]
peter hauer nugebauer
[Applause]
ann cooper kneels
orlando mcmillan nixon
[Music]
[Applause]
matthew holman peele megan lee quimby
[Applause]
maya haley rayford cohen
[Applause]
raj k ramnani
caitlin eileen reese
[Applause]
daniel thomas robinson
katarina paola robles
[Applause]
robert sir bhagwe
matthew phillips signs
[Applause]
m shaw
[Applause]
neelam ire shake
[Applause]
lauren haley singer
talia and pearlman saglin
kevin x tang
sydney rochelle taraso
caitlyn elizabeth ties
[Applause]
ryan patrick vollmer
isabelle sky warner
jason nathaniel weinstein
[Music]
[Applause]
kessie k wilson
[Applause]
[Music]
jackaronda petros
[Applause]
angela you
florentine audley zander
congratulations davenport class of 2021
mr president i have the honor to present
candidates from benjamin franklin
college
for the bachelor's degrees of yale
college
when they have been recommended by the
faculty of yale college
and approved by the corporation ding
chun will ask you
by your official act to confer upon them
these degrees
[Applause]
by the authority vested in me i shall
confer upon you the bachelor's degrees
in yale college when designated by the
dean
and shall then admit you to all their
rights
and responsibilities
tyler joseph janssen banner bear
benjamin franklin college
ashanafi abigail ashwara mukar
marshals for the procession of benjamin
franklin college
[Applause]
kamara aaron
ahmed victoria dawn andrew
paul saint alban atkinson jr
talia baeza milan
jaylen russell bailey
stephanie bang
sarah elizabeth baskin
kieran bocum
christina paz bermudez
evan christopher blasey
ivana boccik
[Music]
t victoria chen
colton ford conley
jason lewis contino
[Music]
isabel silva corpus
[Music]
lauren nicole cueto
[Music]
emma rose deroser
benjamin clifford lee dormis
fred jr abange macaulay
[Applause]
[Music]
aya almensi
madeline freeman
tony gao
charles harrison gardner
angela gong
carolina sophia gonzalez zapata
spencer chase hageman
[Applause]
morgan hannah gattas
[Applause]
amanda deborah hartzell
maximilian pete tempe
oona o'neil holaham
cindy lauren holmes
mina grace hughes
arthur huang
[Applause]
christopher ersfeldt
isabelle elise johnson
[Applause]
jessica lincoln
isabelle kulik
mimi kostaska
sylvia krischuk
michaela therese laronde king
[Music]
olivia lee
sasha lee
[Applause]
sarah melanie lewis
[Music]
catherine lee
shannon ross linder
lauren elise lococo
leila lopez
[Music]
[Applause]
frederick lewis zachary montes
[Applause]
talia nash kuhn morrison allen
olivia mosnoy
juliet catherine neal
iragi and cara
emma caroline osborne
joseph ostuno eric ooh
joseph peck patrick perry
thomas potiglion
caroline pryor
catherine pundick michael pervey jr
aldo ogenio que vero
cindy warner wren imani richardson
[Applause]
logan rivers muriel
rothman mira rothman sorry
zachary austin rudner
abira said
[Music]
isabelle sands francesco mario carlos
carpetta
isaiah schrader
[Applause]
jonathan schwartz vienna gloria stewart
scott excuse me benjamin shelley
donovan slater
alexis stenger
[Applause]
[Music]
paul stanky
faith vasquez
trisha vivirose
gwendolyn maya wallace
kathleen segovia wells
lisa wu amanda zhang
and our graduates participating remotely
he won gladys fing
ryan haygood gabriel hoshino
bruno jednek joanne quack
lucas teclamarium theodore pritzker
vlock
and perry jen congratulations benjamin
franklin
so to the students of the class of 2021
and their parents families and friends
looking on from around the globe
we gather to recognize the extraordinary
accomplishments
of all of you who have worked so hard
to complete your programs of study
we salute your effort your diligence
your talent and your intellect
we also join you in expressing gratitude
for all who have supported you in these
endeavors
your families and friends teachers
and other members of the yale community
congratulations class of 2021
hello class of 2021 i'm brian owens
your class secretary four years have
gone by
in the blink of an eye we've made so
many memories
from the first year snowball fight on
old campus right here
to the 2019 yale harvard game which we
won
in double overtime to the late nights
whether they be in the library
studying for an exam or in the common
room
talking with our suite mates and friends
although our senior year experience has
not been a traditional one
the class of 2021 has made the best of
the situation
when we leave yale in just a few days we
will leave
with memories and friendships that last
a lifetime
here's to the class of 2021 we did it
[Music]
class of 2021 good afternoon my name is
skye ward and i am a member of the
committee that organized class day
which will which will air on youtube
tomorrow at 2 30 p.m
two minutes before 2 30 at 2 28 pm a
special piece written by class day
speaker robert lopez
will be played from harkness tower so
keep your ears open
if you haven't already decorated a funny
hat for class day it's not too late
in fact on your seat today you received
a class day 2021 hat that you might want
to use for that purpose
you'll also find a gift bag which
includes items that represent
long-standing class day traditions
as well as others that are new and
unique to the class of 2021.
in addition to the class day speaker
tomorrow's program also includes remarks
by members of our class
who've put together outstanding original
speeches and because class day is about
all of us
you'll see your own photographs and
video reflections throughout tomorrow's
program
congratulations class of 2021 and see
you at class day
class of 2021 congratulations i am so
happy to be with you
and to celebrate with you today
graduating is a great accomplishment
one of the most important ones of your
life if you think back to when you first
arrived on campus though no one could
have imagined
that you would live through a global
pandemic before reaching this moment
but you did and thanks to your strength
and perseverance
this moment has finally come i'm honored
to recognize all the work that you have
done to get here
much of it with the support of your
family and friends
today is your day and it is theirs too
today is a day for looking back with
pride at everything you have
accomplished
and all the goals you have reached of
course it brings some sadness to
now that you are ending your bright
college years
but today is a commencement a beginning
so now as you look
uh to the days and years ahead think of
the new achievements
and opportunities in front of you and
look around as well
to remind yourself of the excellent
company joining on this new beginning
your friendships formed at yale
tomorrow you will celebrate class day a
tradition stretching back 150 years
and yale college history i'm excited to
watch the virtual program alongside you
and on monday we can look forward to
president salve's commencement address
i am grateful to the class day committee
to the senior class council
to the university secretary's office to
your college heads and deans
and to everyone who contributed to
making this special events of this
weekend possible
and i'm most appreciative to you for all
that you have brought to yale
and will now bring out to the world with
you
again class of 2021 congratulations
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
me
me
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Applause]
um
keep waving
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you